Senegalese astrophysicist Salma Sila is
searching for solutions to some of
Africa's most pressing challenges but
looking into space is not enough she
says
like to go to space because if I can go
to space I can gather precious
information that will be useful for
generations to come it's essential
since the first man in space in 1961
hundreds of astronauts have blasted off
but a black African is yet to make the
journey marikosaga is scientist from
Burkina Faso says it's about time this
changes she's taking part in the new
space Africa conference in Ivory Coast
where scientists companies and investors
gather hoping to change perspectives of
space research
for more than 60 years and yet we
struggle with the same problems hunger
lack of water and agriculture we waste
our money when we should invest in space
research to find long-term Solutions
two one in April Kenya launched its
first satellite joining the few African
countries that have space programs the
images it generates support conservation
efforts by anticipating weather patterns
such as droughts they can even help
protect borders by monitoring the
movements of armed groups in the Sahel
some of the components of satellites are
precious metals and minerals found on
the continent but they cost hundreds of
millions of dollars and take years to
build Omari Chad the Kenyan startup has
the solution Nano satellites
functioning satellite it is Affordable
it is modular and what you do is you
enable the space agencies to
we shorten the launch Windows from a few
years it takes to launch a satellite for
any country to a few months
on a meteorite for Mars researchers
discovered traces of zircon a mineral
found in abundance in Senegal Priscilla
this is no coincidence with only four
percent of the universe known to humans
she says Africans have an important role
to play in discovering what's out there
and how it can be used to improve lives
back on Earth Nicholas Hawk Al Jazeera